heather i am so happy to chat with you i
am giving you et canada pride's mom of
the year award listen honestly heather
there has been so many incredibly
special heartfelt moments watching you
with your children and just being an
accepting supportive mother it's so
important for people to see because
there is still a lot of things within
the lgbtq community that really need to
be worked on so what has it meant for
you to be so honest and open about your
family and receive this overwhelming
amount of support
i mean it's amazing obviously one and
and i was pretty vocal about the fact
that one of the big reasons why i wanted
to come back was to show our family
because it's it's just heartbreaking
what's going on in our country around
the world but specifically in our
country right now in texas and in
florida and all these places and it just
it breaks my heart and when you think
about your parents your parents are
supposed to be if no one else is loving
you or taking care of you at the very
least the people that brought you into
this world and created you
should be there for you and it just it
blows my mind that kids don't have that
so for me with all the drama and the
nonsense of being on shows like this
those scenes
are so special and it's not like hey
look at me what look at what a great mom
i am look at it's not about that it's
about saying
we're doing the best we can here's how
we're doing it talk about it with your
kids accept your kids you know open
conversations in other households i'm
very very proud of that
you should be very proud it's been
incredible because listen you know the
power that you hold as a housewife and
on that series which is you know watched
by millions of people around the world
so it is so important and cat said that
the support you gave her that she
wouldn't be able to be as confident if
she did not have it and listen that's
not lost on me because i truly do not
believe i would be in this position
today if my parents also were not
supportive and accepting when i came out
when i did was there anything that you
did struggle with throughout this
journey with max and kat that maybe you
had to kind of take a step back and
learn something about or was it just
support right from the get-go it was
totally support right from the get-go
but they did teach me and i think in the
show i think i i think i said that to
her but it is it's a cat especially but
max too because she was sort of the
pioneer in the family in the lgbtq plus
community so she kind of paved the way
but kat
she's such a learner of things and she's
so i mean they're both very smart but
i'm just saying like cat was the one
that taught me you know about what you
know pansexual versus bisexual
non-binary what that meant pronouns and
and whose pronouns were appropriate and
how you speak to people and what it
means to them to be seen and heard that
to me was incredible the one thing i
will say though is that
you know i don't like you know of course
there's always going to be negative
backlash there's always going to be
trolls and all that but i have seen some
people say even former castmates of mine
say things like oh you shouldn't bring
this on for a storyline let me be very
clear about something i'm not bringing
anything on as a storyline this is
actually my life which is the point of a
reality show and if you have a platform
such as this guess what open your mouth
and start talking about things because
that's why we have the platform
absolutely and i love that you hit on
that because that was kind of going to
be a question for me there have been
things online about this being a story
line but it's like no this is actually
the reality of your life that you are
living and you are just continuing this
conversation for millions across the
world
you know and the thing is is like all
right so you know the algorithm of our
show is for every 30 hours they film 20
minutes makes it to the air so you can
imagine how much stuff we film i mean
they showed my clothing line the seven
year stitch that terry and i have been
working on for two years they showed our
you know our our skin care products my
podcast like all these things and they
showed none of it because this is what
they wanted to show like i don't have
any control over that i don't need a
storyline when it comes to those sort of
things i have a very full life but i'm
so so glad that they did show it
i'm so glad too because it has been
extremely powerful to be on that
franchise and see something like that
especially for myself as a queer person
i do love the story of when kat did come
out to you via text and you just kind of
listen i feel like maybe you saw it i
don't know but that's what i loved was
that maybe it just wasn't that big of a
deal to you and you're like there's dog
poop in the house yeah like the dog's
crapped in the house what is going on
well because i already knew that cat was
gay it had been a conversation we had
talked about it she was exploring
herself she you know was going through
all the machinations of who is she and
whatever and then she had like an aha
moment and realized that she was she was
a lesbian and that was her moment and i
don't even know if i like saw it or i
thought okay today this what i don't
know it was like okay someone the dogs
pooped in the house who didn't take them
out more pressing issues
exactly right well i think it's super
important as a parent i'm not a parent
myself but i can only imagine as a
parent how important it is to be a
person
and a parental figure that your children
can come and speak to you about anything
that's incredibly special do you feel
like at this point now that the walls
are completely down i know how hard it
can be to have
teenagers i was once a teenager myself
and i know how great it felt to be able
to go to my parents and discuss anything
yeah
i'm very lucky that way i didn't come
from a family like that the family i
came from didn't talk about anything
and so you know for me it was of the you
know utmost importance to create a
family that could talk to each other but
having said that and to your point i
mean i was a teenager too but but the
thing is is that they tell you
especially they tell you that your girls
especially gonna hate you when they're
16 that's not actually true the age is
12 to 14 where everyone becomes a douche
but here's the good news the good news
is they come back and i i've seen it
happen with the first three so i'm
crossing my fingers for coco but you
know it it's so interesting and enjoying
that you know puberty transition
whatever in that kind of douchey stage
they go from being these little it's
true though they go from these kids and
when they come back they're like it's
like they came back down the mountain
and you're like who is this human that
is they talk to you they want to hang
out with you they i i mean
i have adventures with each of them my
son and i are very very close i mean i i
just it's amazing i love it and i have
friends whose kids are even you know in
their 20s and they're like oh wait till
you do that that's even better because
then they travel with you and it's like
you're friends and you're gonna it's
great
it is great what kind of fears do you
have though still maybe about having two
queer children because listen like we
mentioned earlier
don't say gay is a bill right now that
is absolutely disgusting in my opinion
that this is getting passed and as far
as we have come as
queer people there is still always work
to be done and as a parent you must have
some fears about these children going
out into the world well of course i do i
mean i i'm you know as a parent i'm
worried about everything for them you
know but i feel like they have um all
four of them have really
um
an understanding of who they are as
individuals they've got a great support
system and you know look you might think
because
they grew up in a house like this or
they lived the life we leave that they
would be entitled and they're honestly
really not they're really grounded nice
kids and um i love that about them and
and i it'll be interesting to see the
paths that they go to take but it's
funny if you just look at max and kat
it's very interesting the difference
especially in the queer community max is
irritated that it's a thing meaning
she's like it's so normal that why do
why should we be talking about this like
my brother didn't have to like make a
big deal that he's straight like who
cares this shouldn't be a thing but then
kat is you know i think she'll be a
civil rights attorney i'm not sure but
that cat is more like ready to stand
norma ray on the table and scream it to
to everyone and make people listen so
it's just it's kind of interesting how
everyone process it and and all of it
but i i i love but maxine wrote a book
and you know she and has a podcast and
she's you know keeping the conversations
open and i and i love that about them
yeah that that's fantastic the podcast
the book that is super helpful to a lot
of parents out there for sure what has
it been like seeing cat and max's
relationship through all this there's
been ups and downs that's for sure but
now they kind of have
a big bond between them you know what i
mean have you seen that kind of change
within the two of their relationship i
mean honestly their siblings their girls
and they're teenagers so i'll let you
figure that one out
good point good point so from your own
journey on this
what do you think you can say to other
parents out there who may be struggling
with accepting their own queer children
man just listen listen and communicate
and listen you know i think as parents
so many of us just want to talk and talk
and talk at our children and give them
our life lessons and give them our words
of wisdom by the way super hard for me
because i talk for a living and so but
the truth is they just want to be heard
they just want someone to listen accept
them and love them and that's it
and and
it's biology people this is not a choice
this is biology you got blue eyes you're
straight you're queer you got brown hair
it's just biology
it's just life and it makes things so
much more interesting you know what i
mean there is a huge world out there of
diverse people and that's what i love
about being on this planet because if
everybody was straight
it might be a little boring just
just say
great
on a recent uh episode cat spoke about
you know the bullying that she has faced
and that's super difficult i was bullied
in school as well myself for being gay
um what's the best advice that you think
you've given her over that time
to just kind of make her stay strong
within who she is
you know what we really talk about is
that it really doesn't matter if you're
straight or gay people are mean and
whether it's in person middle school's
the worst i don't know who invented
middle school but it should be you know
abolished
um middle school and you know especially
i think especially females at that age
um are not very nice to each other they
haven't really learned the female
empowerment life lessons most of them
and so we talk a lot about finding your
circle and surrounding yourself with
really positive people how to not pay
attention to the trolls on social media
because i would tell you that a little
bit of a side note one thing that has
completely shocked me is since i first
began the show to taking a break to
coming back so it's been 10 years since
i first started
i cannot believe and i love twitter i
cannot believe the cesspool
that is twitter it is the meanest thing
i've ever seen and even when people like
you
they hate you and the vitriol on there
is just
amazing but i would say like what i've
noticed with my kids is that
they
seem to be able to digest it and and
throw it away easier i don't know if
it's because they were raised with it
and you know for me and my generation
it's like like at a left field like oh
they don't like me or you know it's very
hard yeah
it is hard and that is something that
comes with the territory of course but
it never gets easier when you see
somebody
thing on you
it never gets easier it really won't but
as long as you know who you are and
that's a lesson that i've learned myself
the rest doesn't matter you know it
really really doesn't well listen you
are fantastic i've enjoyed chatting with
you so much i really do appreciate you
taking the time and again it has just
been so powerful to see the love and
acceptance within your family and it
just makes me really really happy so
thank you for that and i know that there
are people out there watching
that can really connect and relate to
your story and that within itself truly
is powerful i i can't tell you like i'm
getting teary listening to you like
that's that's just means so much to me
it really does listen it is not an easy
thing to grow up queer it wasn't when i
was younger it's still not now like we
said with the don't say gay bill like
my mind when i see that in the news i
just want to rage i want like i cannot
believe that this is 2022 so honestly
you sharing this on a platform like that
is powerful and thanks to max and cat as
well for being honest about who they are
and truthful and being proud of who they
are
i'll tell them you said so thanks again
you